alors bassam je veux le dire vous êtes
rue montorgueil est ce que la mesure est
appliquée par tous effectivement amiral
à mesure sans veut être appliquée ici
heureux montorgueil les riverains nous
semble avoir pris au sérieux cette
recommandation de la préfecture de paris
donc des masques et s'ils y sont nés ici
dans la rue on a pu observer depuis ce
matin que des patrouilles de police
municipale et des services de sécurité
de la ville veiller au port du masque en
faisant de la prévention je vous
rappelle une amende de 135 euros
pourrait être affiché à toute personne
ne perdant pas le masque dans les rues
qui ont été décidées par la préfecture
de paris pour le moment l'heure est à la
prévention dans les rues de la capitale
tous les arrondissements à peu près sont
concernés par cette nouvelle mesure
objectifs du gouvernement et surtout
objectifs de la ville de paris limiter
la propagation du virus surtout dans les
endroits où la dispensation social est
compliquée à appliquer à faire respecter
qui est certains arrondissements
certains quartiers dont ici rue
montorgueil ou encore la butte
montmartre sur les quais tout le monde
respecte à peu près 7 consignes depuis
ce matin 8h on a pu échanger avec
certains riverains ici rue montorgueil
depuis ce matin je vous propose de les
écouter
c'est une bonne mesure je pense que ça
devrait être généralisé c'est une
manière de faire attention à soi bien
sûr mais de faire attention aux autres
c'est plus regardées savoir dans quelle
rue pourquoi donc moi j'ai pris le
l'option je vais le porter tout le temps
fait quand je sors et comme ça je me
pose pas la question est ce que je suis
dans la bonne rue est-ce que voilà tout
ça moi je suis pour la globalité
voilà c'est la meilleure façon d'enrayer
justement de moi je pense que c'est
normal mais ils prennent des mesures ils
ne sont pas fait assez à d'autres ceux
qui le mettent d'autres qui ne l'est pas
il ya d'autres pays on donne les amendes
de 1000 euros
si on pouvait donner même poids mille
héros ici c'est parce que rendu
obligatoire dans plusieurs rues de la
capitale comme je l ai dit depuis ce
matin 8h beaucoup de personnes ne sont
pas encore au courant de cette mesure
d'où la prévention et l'intervention de
certains policiers municipaux où
certains membres de la sécurité de la
ville de paris la préfecture a déclaré
que cette mesure prendra effet à partir
de ce matin et ce pour un mois objectif
limiter la propagation de ce virus mais
énormément de personnes se questionne
sur les rues qui ont été sélectionnés
par la préfecture de paris pourquoi une
rue et pas une autre
la préfecture de paris déclare qu'il
faut mettre un match dans toutes les
zones très fréquentées surtout les zones
touristiques
mais bizarrement l'avenue des champs
elysées ou encore la rue de rivoli ce
sont des rues très fréquenté notamment
par les touristes ou le bord du mas
n'est pas obligatoire voilà on va
essayer de voir un petit peu comment
cette mesure est appliquée dans
l'ensemble de la capitale
une mesure décidée par la préfecture de
paris depuis ce matin 8 heures